now remember the AP reported that the US
will accept 85,000 refugees in 2016
100,000 and 2017 that equals 185,000
that on top of the 70,000 refugees this
year all told
255,000 many from Syria not all by any
means joining us now with reaction the
director of jihad watch Robert Spencer
from the Islamic House of Wisdom imam
muhammad ali allah he and the president
for at for America Brigitte Gabriel a
mom let me a mom let me start with you
now if we have the Director of National
Intelligence James clapper and we have
State Department spokesman John Kirby
and we have James Comey who you heard an
assistant director of the FBI Michael
Steinbeck and Homeland Security
Committee Chair Mike McCall all saying
it's impossible to vet the 10,000 that
the president insisted today will take
in from Syria why should we risk one
American getting hurt in light of what
the events in Paris show you how it let
me why should we risk one American life
if they're telling us we cannot bet them
all can you explain to the American
people why we should do that I explained
to American people that we have to deal
with the causes not the effects I just
have
serious the people of Syria used to live
under a secular government in peace and
prosperity a government that was not
working no superhero for that they had
not the intention of have Sharia law
like Saudi Arabia start your buzzer you
don't know you don't know women if one
of the terrorists in Paris got through
the the refugee system there and they're
warning us it can happen here I'll throw
this tube Rashid Rashid one plus one
equals two would be safe to assume that
our intelligence officials are right and
this is a danger to the american people
we have to stop the criminals we have to
attain that regime right is it possible
to make circulation to the American
people because our intelligence agencies
are monitoring the situation look even
Isis came out and said we already have
4,000 Isis people smuggled into Europe
as refugees Isis figured it out and they
know they're going to send them here
within the refugees our intelligence
community knows it and that's why we
have to be very careful Robert Spencer
really quick to you why should the
people of America allow when our
intelligence agency says they cannot
that they will infiltrate the refugee
community why would the president insist
on doing that isn't that gambling with
the lives of the American people it is a
definite gambling with the motor on to
people things happen in Paris it
attacked like what happened in Paris is
very likely to happen here as a result
of this look the Obama administration
won't even acknowledge or name the enemy
or admit that there's an ideology behind
it and so how are they going to vet when
they won't even admit that this ideology
exists how are they going to vet for it
there's absolutely no way and it's
absurd and it's it's bordering on
suicidal it's definitely very much
against American interests and not one
refugee should come here Republican
Congress better take note and they
better stop it and coming up next thank
you all right here tonight on Hannity